[Music]
the thing about Jimmy savle um and I
started uh writing in the books like the
biggest secret which came out in 1998 um
I I wrote about all of this stuff it was
very clear from what's come out is the
police knew about
him um special Branch that's supposed to
protect the royal family absolutely
would have known about him British
intelligence knew about him even the
locals in the area the rumors were rif
yes yeah even like just regular folk on
the street knew but he was never colored
for it and then um you start to look in
the background um first of all in his
own
words he was invited into the inner core
of the British royal family in the
1960s by a man called Lord mount baton
Lord mount Batton was a known pedophile
he was Infamous for it has that been
proven officially oh yes oh I mean
people come out and they they've talked
about being abused by it but you know I
I I've seen loads about this I I don't I
don't cross the line and say this is how
it is unless unless I've reached a point
where I've got so much information from
no different people and so a known
pedophile brings savil into the inner
core of the British royal family where
he becomes a close friend of Prince
philli till they had a big falling out
apparently and a close friend to his
death of Prince Charles now King Charles
um and he was in with a politician such
as thater well well yeah again um he was
he was a friend of Margaret thater and
it was Margaret Thatcher's cabinet that
all the stories came out about the how
many pedophiles there were in in in
Thatcher's cabinet her father um who ran
a a grocery store in Grantham was a
known bloody uh uh pedophile uh I mean
that the girls were warned not to take a
job at his shot you know everywhere um
and so anyway um what um savil was doing
was
like people
knew but he was never collored cuz what
he was doing and this has not come out
he was um a procurer of children for the
Rich and Famous he was supplying
children this has come out through at
least one member of his family but but
and it has come out through other
sources through the it's not been
broadcast in the way everything else was
it's not it's not coming out through the
Main Street yeah um and uh so Ted Heath
right Ted Heath um the prime minister of
Britain who took us into the European uh
what became the European Union the
EC um he was a
pedophile and a Satanist and I said so
in the biggest secret and that book was
read to him uh in the week of
publication when he was still a member
of parliament how long ago was this this
was
1998 and um it was 17 years before the
um the Wiltshire police did an
investigation into Heath pedophilia and
said if he was alive today we would open
an investigation we we we would we would
be questioning him on on this because
what was his response when they read it
to him he said he just said David I must
be mad and that was it that was there
was no other response
and um I wasn't uh that's what he did um
and and savvo was supplying children for
him this this has come come out through
various different sources not least in
the uh the so-called care home in Jersey
which uh came to prominence at one point
involving Ted Heath and I'll tell you
I'll tell you a quick was that the one
that s was the yeah that he used to
visit cuz I've seen a clip of him just
for reference here just so people know
that there's you know from what I've
seen even and there was a clip of him
talking to a little girl I think on the
in the bed and and she was really scared
of him and he said what have I done to
make you so scared of me and she said
everything and it was chilling it was
horrific people were scared of him not
not least because and not least media
people were scared because of his
connections when you're supplying
children for pedophilia and Sacrifice by
the way um to to the Rich and Famous
networks of the cult cuz there were lots
that W missing right yeah exactly on the
number of kids go missing I mean PE
people relate the number of kids go
missing to the number of missing
children stories on the news forget that
vastly greater than that you never hear
most of them um and and so um they were
um when you're supplying them with with
with with children you you don't get
collared first of all uh for what you're
doing anyone that threatens to exposure
well they better watch their back as
well cuz the same people are watching
his back and I tell B like what happened
in America to um Epstein you know he he
was in jail he was ready to testify boom
yeah well well you know they tried to
protect him they protected him once
first round and then where the the women
wouldn't give up she um uh or they um
had to uh stop him coming into court and
all coming out whether they killed him
or whether they didn't that's that's an
open question that people have but
certainly he was he was disappeared and
and by the way on on our um our media
platform iconic we have a um a program
um called classified which which is
really you know to looking at the far
out stuff and uh uh recently um we
interviewed A lady called um briyan
Juliet Bryant who is a a known um girl
that was abused in the Epstein Network
and she describes on that show how she
short saw him shift from a what she she
described as from a human form to a
dragon type form and why they're doing
the same sacrificial rituals now with
these rich of famous billionaires as
they were doing back then in Babylon and
so
on it's because
um when you um you are going through the
ritual you've got your sacrificial
victim often a child by the way and
there's there's a reason for that you
know when they talk about uh the
Ancients um sacrificing young virgins to
the gods that was children basically
that's what we're talking
about what they're doing is
systematically um triggering Terror in
the in the sacrificial victim the
greater the terror they can elicit the
greater the uh offering to the gods so
it's all about terrorizing the victim
when people are are are exhibiting um
emot
uh uh or thought energy um like Terror
for instance you can see the body
language of how they're feeling because
they're screaming or they're terrified
or whatever and if you're
sensitive you can pick up these
vibrations uh and you can feel what
they're feeling when you when when you
know people saying oh I'm fine mate
honestly I'm fine but you can feel it
you're not fine are you you know what
it's it's just because you're mentioning
this uh because of all the the issues
we've been seeing on social media from
uh Gaza seeing all these children all
over my uh Twitter timeline crying and
upset it hits you immediately like you
feel it yeah it's a it's it's a
vibrational connection you're picking up
what they're giving
off um and so
um you can feel that and you can see the
body language what you can't do is see
the frequency
mhm why cuz they're being given off
outside of our pH human system and
they're going into this astral Dimension
that's why we can't see them that's why
we can't see the astral unless we have
psychic
abilities and these Gods on this
peripheral lower frequency band of this
astral Dimension are absorbing these
frequencies which the sacrifice is
giving off that's
the sacrifice to the gods and what
happens in this world of the the
satanists who are doing this in our
reality in the human reality um they
then drink the blood of the sacrifice
because the chemical expression of that
Terror releases an adrenaline into the
blood which to them is like a drug it's
like a high and they drink the blood and
people have have seen this happen have
described how they when they drink the
blood they go bloody wild often because
of the effect it has upon them and this
is where adrenochrome comes from and
then I'm investigating these rich and
famous billionaires of today who are
players in this cult and again and again
and again I'm led into Satanism and
pedophilia those two are absolutely
connected um for reasons I explain in
the books
and what are these bloody billionaires
doing Satanic ritual sacrifices to to
their version of the Gods right it's
just like the old God where we SE in the
footage that Alex Jones took yeah in
Bohemian gr George Bush and all of them
were there alore was there they're
they're doing it to the same Gods right
the same freaking entities that the
Ancients were doing the sacrifices to
and were terrified of
these people today are doing the
sacrifices to in the
coal um and I've talked to people all
over the world um over the decades I've
been doing this a long time um 34 years
I'm I've been doing it now now coming up
34 years and I've met satanists and
people that took part in rituals against
their will who have have told me of
their experiences and the these are
major major players like the royal
family British royal family Dutch royal
family all that stuff all major players
in this um in this Satanic ritual um
culture um and so then I asked that
question I I mentioned a few minutes ago
oh so what did the gods get out of it I
take you back to the first Matrix movie
and the Morpheus character holds up a
battery and he says the Matrix is a
computer generated dream world designed
to turn humans into one of these a
battery and that's when uh
a massive understanding started to uh
started to come to me from many
different sources which I talk about in
the
books
these quote Gods these entities are
feeding of human energy but it's a
particular type of human
energy um this is mainstream science
again every time we feel emotion every
time we think we're generating
frequencies and those frequencies in
terms of what the frequencies are relate
to the nature of the emotion and the
nature of the thought and scientists
have worked out what these frequencies
are for different emotions right and um
it's all like when you go into a room
and you kind of feel like oh there's a a
bad energy in here yeah you know what I
mean yeah I mean if if you go into like
an old house where there's been a lot of
uh really bad things going on there see
when the bad things are going on the
people involved in the bad things are
giving off that Vibe and unless someone
goes into that house and changes the
frequency they sit there vibrating so
you go into it and you think oh this is
horrible God because you're picking the
vibe up right so this is these are the
energies I'm talking about so these
entities by their very
nature um are very low VI ational in
nature because anyone that wants to
impose their will and manipulate and
cause suffering and War and death and
destruction is in a very low vibrational
State and if they're going to feed off
human energy they can only feed off it
if we are delivering it within the band
of frequency they can absorb because um
otherwise if we were uh in a world of
love and joy and happiness and peace
then we'd be giving off frequencies yes
but much higher more expanded
frequencies and they wouldn't be able to
absorb them like radio stations in the
old analog system sharing the same space
but not interfering with each other
because they're on different wavelengths
to give off the frequencies that they
can absorb we have to be in fear
anxiety depression
resentment regret they must had a fi
over Co well yeah I mean Brian look at
what's happening as we speak in uh
Israel Gaza look what's happening in
Ukraine look what happened in the first
world war second world war look what
they planned for the third world war and
it's just an
absolute explosion of low
vibrational emotional particularly
emotional but mental too energy which
they're feeding off now we can start to
understand
[Music]
and